For our animation we could use the Javascript native function setTimeout,
which simply runs a function after a specified number of milliseconds.
Even better for our use case we will use the function setInterval,
which can be thought of setTimeout's sister, which function in the same way and
runs a function after a specified number of milliseconds.
But in setInterval's case, it repeatedly runs that function.
For our case, this is exactly what we want to do to run our update function,
repeatedly, once for every year of the World Cup.
And to know what years to loop over, we're going to use an array,
that stores all the years of the World Cup, and to populate this array,
I'm just going to loop through the years, between 1930 and 2015.